[Music]
this week on world stories India
breaking down the barriers Nigeria a zoo
enjoys a revival but we begin in the
u.s. where President Trump is planning
the deportation of millions of
undocumented immigrants we take a look
at one neighborhood in New York worried
faces at a neighborhood meeting in
Staten Island a few days ago two
Mexicans were arrested in the borough
and deported Marybel Torres has come to
learn more about the latest series of
raids the mother of two children has
been living in the United States
illegally for 12 years I'm very scared I
might be separated for my children and
family my children are very scared too
so we have to prepare for this case the
Trump administration says it is mainly
deporting undocumented immigrants with a
criminal record but many here are still
afraid community activist Gonzalo
Mercado organized the meeting lawyers
specializing in immigration law are also
attending they say the raids go too far
everybody has rights if immigration
comes to the house or their job so we're
going to talk about a nice about those
rights and how can people prepare
themselves also in their families we're
gonna give them an emergency packet
where they're gonna put all the
information from their children from
their church from their bank accounts
that they can use in case of emergency
the owner is explained that no one needs
to allow the police into their home
without a search or arrest warrant they
say neighbors can help by calling a
lawyer if they see a raid Gonzalo
Mercado wants to bring neighbors
regardless of whether they are US
citizens together into one community
happily the whole community being able
to be here and supporting each other
it's definitely a positive thing for all
of us in case of anything happening they
will show support and fight for each
other here with folks like myself
reaching out the meeting ends on an
upbeat note but the uncertainty remains
deportations happened under the Obama
administration - but since Donald Trump
became president undocumented immigrants
in the US are more frightened about
their future
[Music]
working as a truck mechanic is usually
considered a man's job in most places in
the world but in India one woman is
challenging the stereotype
[Music]
shanti devi at work she replaces truck
tires checks them for wear and tear and
fixes flats in a sari and bangle
she's an unusual figure in sanjay gandhi
transport another a huge trucking hub in
not Delhi an estimated 20,000 trucks
rolled by every day thousands more are
parked here for repairs and refueling
Shanti Devi and her husband set up a tea
shop here 20 years ago they expanded the
business to start a tire of their
workshop
the shop is hard work the to put in at
least 10 hours every day sometimes more
the tyres weigh at least 50 kilos and
have to be moved around the shop has no
toilet and no electricity connection
look that's an old tire it's travelled
thousands of kilometres through slush
and mud and God knows what else you have
to be prepared to get your hands dirty
it's a tough job hard work is something
the 55 year old is used to she grew up
in poverty in the central Indian state
of Madhya Pradesh working all her life
as a seamstress and in a cigarette
factory to make ends meet her husband
ram bahadur says he initially had doubts
about his wife working with him in a
trucking center but she's crude to metal
it's a man strong but he who had a woman
who is doing a man's job
but her presence in an environment
heavily dominated by men
still raises eyebrows here I've
travelled a lot in my life and I've
never seen anything like this a woman
working as a truck mechanic and really
amazed I don't think this work is
you need a lot of strength for this you
have to change tires pickin boots men
are more knowledgeable bugs but muhammad
islam who was hired as a mechanic by
shanti devi disagrees I have no problem
working we worked together as a team
Shanti and a husband make around four
hundred and seventy euros a month
they saved enough to build a house which
they share with the children and the
families though Shanti Devi herself was
unable to bear school she's determined
that her granddaughters get a good
education earlier people used to say why
educate a girl she's going to get
married anyway
and will stay at home but that's wrong
it's important for women not to stand on
her own feet so that she can feed
herself and her children Shanti Devi is
now urging her daughters-in-law
to learn sewing and get some part-time
work she's very inspiring you realize
that women can do any job and they're
equal to men Shanti Devi hopes her story
will embolden other women to break
barriers
years of austerity in Greece have led to
unemployment poverty and hardship for
many now the crisis is also affecting
the country's once affluent professional
classes
[Music]
it doesn't matter how loudly they
advertise their wares or how busy it is
there's hardly anyone buying anything at
column areas weekly market let alone the
more expensive products like fish and
exotic fruits and veg and that's
although the town is relatively well-off
there are high earners here
entrepreneurs freelancers Callum area is
home to northern Greece's upper middle
class like gallery owner Marta varruchi
till 2012 was very good for me but then
I realized that the situation is going
down and I decided to close the store
that was the only way she could avoid
bankruptcy today she relies on food
donations from the local welfare center
her savings are long gone and she gets
no state support
I lost my pride my life was perfect
now now it's nothing and she's not alone
the vicious circle of banking crisis tax
hikes and government austerity measures
is ruining Greece's middle class
Constantino gugus was a successful
architect now he finds he often can't
afford to pay his electricity bill if I
can pay I pay but if not I don't care
they won't switch it off because if they
do there'll be a revolution further
austerity more cuts that would simply
strip people here of their basic
livelihoods the result is just more
poverty we already see more and more
people searching through rubbish bins to
find food only for you dog
residents have less to spend so there
are less takings at kalam areas market
and that means less tax revenue for the
Greek government which is already
struggling to repay its foreign debt
our last report takes us to Nigeria and
the northeastern town of Maiduguri the
local zoo has been restocked and the
animals fed a sign that hope is
returning to a region long scarred by
terrorism elephants ostriches and even a
lion many here are seeing these animals
for the first time in their lives it's
great for us kids to come to the zoo and
see all the wild animals before they do
Cory is a place that people that you
know come because of the insurgency
there's a reason that most of the people
there are not coming what I'm coming to
because of the fish does the reason that
because of the visit and come to that
place to see the animals and orders the
zoo isn't mad agouti a city that has
only been in the headlines recently
because of terrorism the zoo is the only
place in town where you can relax and
let your mind wander entry has just 10
cents the director says the place
suffered a lot when Boko Haram were in
control here at the peak of all the
troubles some of the animals staff to
death out of desperation some of the
zoo's goats were sacrificed to feed the
crocodiles and lions
the previous government before this
governor the governor was neglected even
did pretty infrared the government is
not giving us enough no amount to give
us to feed animals but thank God with
this present come on
even the freebies years of insulation
here such as giving a speedy impressed
so that was why we have started cleaning
the cage and all the place had become
beauty we deleted that we are getting
probably come on the director says the
number of visitors just keeps on growing
he wants to make sure they'll soon have
even more animals to see
[Music]
you